de oude healer zei tegen de ziel
het is niet je rug die pijn doet
maar het is de last die je draagt
het zijn niet je ogen die pijn doen
maar het is het onrecht dat je ziet
het is niet je hoofd dat pijn doet
maar je gedachten die pijn doen
het is niet je keel die pijn doet
maar datgene wat jij niet durft te vertellen
naar die buitenwereld
het is niet je buik die pijn doet
maar je ziel die niet kan verteren
wat het rondom heen allemaal ziet
het is niet je lever die pijn doet
het is de boosheid
die je van binnen voelt die pijn doet
het is niet je hart die pijn doet
maar het gebrek
aan liefde die pijn doet
het is de liefde zelf die al deze pijn kan genezen
waarom liefde is het meest krachtige medicijn op aarde